we are told researchers scored 31
athletes on an agility test here are
their scores it's in this histogram and
what I'm going to ask you is which of
these intervals interval a B or C which
one contains the median of the scores
and which one or give an estimate of
which one contains the mean of the
scores pause this video and see if you
can figure that out so let's just start
with the median remember the median you
could view as the middle number or if
you have an even number of data points
it would be the average of the middle
two here we have an odd number of data
points so it would be the middle number
so what would be the middle number if
you were to order them from least to
greatest well it would be the one that
has 15 on either side so it would be the
sixteenth it would be the sixteenth data
point sixteenth data point and so we
could just think about which interval
here contains the sixteenth data point
you could view it for the sixteenth from
the highest or the sixteenth from the
lowest it is the middle one all right so
let's start from the highest so this
interval C contains the 13 highest data
points and then interval B goes from the
14th highest all the way to the 18th
highest so this B contains the median it
contains the 16th highest data point or
if you started from the left it would
also be the 16th lowest data point so
that's where the median is the median
now what about an estimate for the mean
well you have calculated the mean in the
past but when you're looking at a
distribution like this when you're
looking at a histogram one way to think
about the mean is it would be the
balancing point if you imagine that this
histogram was made out of some material
of let's say uniform density where would
you put a fulcrum in order to balance it
if you put the fulcrum right over here
it feels like you would have it feels
like you would tip over to the left
because this is a left skewed
distribution you have this long tail to
the left
if you really wanted to balance it out
it seems like you would have to move
your fulcrum in the direction of that
left skew in the direction of the tail
and so I would estimate to balance it
out it would actually be closer to that
which would be interval a interval a
would contain the mean the intention of
this type of exercise isn't for you to
try to calculate every data point in
fact they don't give you all the
information here and add them all up and
then divide by 31 it's really to
estimate and to also get the intuition
that when you have a left skewed
distribution like this you will often
see a situation where your mean is to
the left of the median if you have a
right skewed distribution it would be
the other way around and as we will see
when you see a symmetric distribution
the mean and the median will be awfully
close to each other or when you have a
roughly symmetric distribution if you
have a perfectly symmetric distribution
they might be exactly in the same place
so let's do another example so here it
says we have the ages of 14 co-workers
and what I want you to do is say roughly
where is the mean and roughly where is
the median is it roughly at a is it
roughly at B or is it roughly at C pause
this video and try to figure it out so
let's first start off with the median we
have 14 data points so this would be the
average of the middle two data points it
was the it would be the average of the
seventh and eighth data point well you
could say one two three four five six
seven and then the eighth one is here so
the seventh data point is a 30 the
eighth one is in the thirty one bucket
so the average of the two would you get
U to be another way that you could think
about it is you can just eyeball it and
see you have just as many data points
below B as you do have above B and so
that also gives you a good indication
that B would be where the median is so
that is where the meeting is now what
about the mean well this is a perfectly
symmetric distribution if I wanted to
balance it I would put the fulcrum right
in the middle so I
would say that the mean would also the
mean would also be at B and we are done